these men look good and have red hair as
kids they were made fun of but now they
look like self-confident and some pinup
idols when you look at these pictures
you look kind of looking up at them as
almost this heroic masculine figure if
ginger hair was a brand it's trying to
UM create the the ultimate dream of
being a ginger man fashion photographer
Thomas Knight's from London is a man on
a mission he wants to improve the image
of the ginger man his exhibition red hot
opens this weekend in Berlin he makes
the final touches ahead of the big day
as a redhead he knows how people with
his hair color suffer especially
children in popular culture in general
but especially in the UK there is this
very anti ginger sentiment of real kind
of anti redhead notion and when when you
grow up as a redhead
you totally sense it you feel it you
know you live it and and when you're
constantly told but it's a bad thing
it's a negative thing it's unattractive
you you totally take that on board but
these bare-chested models paint a very
different picture this is the trailer
Thomas Nights uses to advertise his
project he started looking for models in
2010 but supposedly no agency in Britain
had red headed models so he had to go
and look on his own
in the hip London district of Soho he
discovered ken Beck the Dane was working
in a juice bar as a child other kids
used to make fun of him and call him
strawberry helmet he never dreamed of
becoming a model Thomas came through the
door and it was super busy he jumped the
queue and come up to a standing juicing
and pulls out this calendar with the
ginger people half-naked and he starts
asking me do you want to be a part of
this and obviously I go like no and but
he left his business card and one of my
colleagues that kind of pushed me why
not what do you got to lose
Kent Beck is now the cover boy of the
red hot campaign his face is on
calendars and posters he gave up the job
in the juice bar to become a full-time
model he does fashion shootings with
Thomas nights and now he has contracts
with agencies in London New York and
Paris but Beck and nights and all of the
redheads are in the minority they're
estimated to be 140 million redheads
worldwide that's about 2% of the planet
in Britain the percentage is higher and
there are many famous people with ginger
looks Prince Harry for instance or the
musician Ed Sheeran but despite this
Thomas Knight says red-haired men often
get a raw deal in films and on TV in
Hollywood there's many redheaded females
like Julianne Moore in Nicole Kidman who
was who are sex symbols and was seen as
aspirational to other women that is sort
of the ultimate woman they're seen as a
sexual they're seen as something to
aspire towards and you just still don't
get that for the for the ginger man so
say take Harry Potter you know you've
got the wonderful character of Ron
Weasley and his whole family but they
want they aren't the powerful family
they aren't they aren't the heroes even
Damian Lewis in home lands he ended up
being the anti-hero he was he was in
fact the the the negative character in
the end
that's why Knights would like to take
his exhibition to Hollywood he wants to
create debate in Tinseltown so far his
pictures have been in London New York in
Sydney in Berlin people were already
checking out the exhibition even while
it was still being set up
Judah's i chat them up they're not what
you'd expect it's mundane soonerlater
beautiful people not all my type but
most are little good especially this one
another project is the anti-bullying
calendar nights is looking for models in
Berlin the profits go to institutions
that work against marginalization at
British schools night says he receives
thank you mails every day from people
who've been affected or from their
family members I think it has actually
made an impact I don't know whether we
are at a point where children are not
getting bullied at school for being
ginger I don't think that's quite
happening yet but I'm hoping that that
eventually might come with my ultimate
goal which would be something like a
ginger James Bond a major kind of
Hollywood character that is you know a
heartthrob lead leading man being ginger
it's a dream that one day could be
reality
Thomas Nights has already found a
hundred possible candidates
you